io non so perché ma all'inizio la fine
dei video finisco sempre per registrarli
in pigiama tanto ormai eletti ragazzi e
benvenuti a questo numero sono fa vj ed
oggi siamo in un nuovo blog quando siamo
andati in giappone abbiamo fatto tre
giorni di fila all'ultra music festival
non avevo ancora praticamente messo
nulla del trapano ancora niente ho
deciso di raccogliere tutto quanto in un
video solo e di mettere tutte le cose
insieme così da farvi vedere quanta
sobrietà c'era in quei giorni buona
visione ragazze incazzato nero
canottiera alla vino biologico
siete pronti per questo festival
le mani sasha
[Applauso]
ma il papa
[Musica]
va bene
my dad mouse si sarà il tatuaggio
cosa c'è stefanino
9 tornerà
posso che darti chiuse perché stai
camminando ai piedi scalzi in mezzo alla
strada in giappone a strade più pulite
le nostre case
per questo non ti accontenti capacità
adesso io non camminerò scalzo non papa
non miss camminerò scavo
ma cosa vuoi cosa vuol dire sto
camminando scalzi sulla 48ma la
situazione to provano papa ha assunto le
droghe papa non è un papa buono perché
stiamo facendo questa cosa qua il quale
il nostro problema di papà perché quello
alle manine in culo papa non si fa
perché ha le mani nel culo quasi topless
e deve però quello lo sta toccando
papale asiatico e cinese i cinesi si
toccano puro papa ma fa anche suri papa
ma il primo che piega le mani di culo
[Applauso]
si no
michael ma la vice agiamo vai vai zio
[Applauso]
bene
dato che i ragazzi avete visto novità
siamo in su non lo so mi sto perdendo
sempre benvenuti a questo nuovo video e
giappone
quando devo farlo entro l'anno
dai nonni domani
domani il giro morto
[Applauso]
mai
e cazzo fai domani piove
che casta
[Musica]
lo spazio
andiamo a bagno cucinare metanfetamina
no niente ragazzi allora succede che
piove e noi due cristiani invece di
prendere l'ombrello come bravi cristiani
siccome io c'ho la pigrizia nell'anima e
non ci voglia di tenere l'ombrello ho
deciso lui è un boss
ho deciso di dimettere sto coso così non
mi bagna ora come contenuto papà di
andare all'ultra che superi vanti acari
aj chi sta arrivando
una parola
[Musica]
è una fauna borghesi cuore di grande
aiuto come siamo ridotti cosa cosa
succede che cazzo te fischi
allora queste garics siamo quasi alla
fine lui è mio amico saluto amico
salutato
ecco
da vedere
[Musica]
[Applauso]
italia lasciatemi piace ciao io mi fate
capire da un minore di scrittrici ma che
cazzo dici papà cosa gli hai dato due
pensieri che cosa cazzo state facendo
[Applauso]
a chi sa cosa sta succedendo
cosa ci fa problemi e incamera così
senza sensi sorrivoli adesso irritato in
mutande ai dove il coltello
i ragazzi questo è stato l'ultra japan
2016 è stato veramente figo perché molti
mi hanno fatto la domanda quando sono
tornato se è meglio il tomorrowland o
l'altra japan il fatto è che il tamarro
land per arrivare davanti al palco devi
sbracciare come un caimano perché ci sta
gente che proviene da qualsiasi paese
puntualmente non sei mai dove vorresti
essere non vedi mai quasi un cazzo
perché c'è una mandria di gente
all'ultra japan diversissimo perché
latin giapponese ti fanno proprio
passare cioè se è vero che anche se
indietro di fanti l'economia niente una
roba mai vista a livello di come mi sono
sentito per me è stato meglio l'ultra
japan ma perché me la son vissuta
diecimila volte meglio anche se il
tomorrow land è pieno di stage di colori
di
di [ __ ] macché l'ultra japan adesso che
ci penso che abbiamo conosciuto delle
ragazze che stavano lì e dopo aver
bevuto un paio di drink ci hanno portati
non pensate ma ci hanno portati a fare a
me email karaoke abbiamo cantato al
karaoke
io e email se volete video sul karaoke
perché ciò delle riprese che fanno
spavento 60 6.666 like vedere cassoli
spero che vi sia piaciuto è stato
wow veramente cosa sai cosa mi è
piaciuto ragazzi lasciate un commento è
un mi piace anche la pace di facebook e
come vino nella descrizione sensore si
rischia temi ci dividiamo il consiglio
video ei ragazzi